if you're wondering where is dr. Anthony
Fauci where has he been lately he has
not been talking to Donald Trump that we
know dr. fowey has been less and less
frequently seen publicly but we've now
learned that dr. foul Chi has not
briefed Donald Trump on coronavirus in
two months has been dissuaded from doing
too many public interviews by the Trump
administration and if you're surprised
by this you've just not been paying
attention months ago the Trump
administration stopped the coronavirus
press briefings especially after the
entire look at injecting bleach and
alcohol fiasco that Donald Trump was
involved in and for all intents and
purposes they've decided this is a
political decision not a medical one
they've decided the pandemic is over
we're reopening now if there are embers
we will put them out we've done the best
testing and the most testing and we've
got therapeutics and vaccines are going
well and all of this stuff ouchy signals
you know I don't know that things are
going that well he says I'm speaking to
Trump less and less frequently I'm
briefing Trump less and less frequency
frequently Trump takes on the language
of victory and we just see dr. Anthony
Fauci almost completely disappeared in
the last 10 days doctor foul he starts
being really clear we're not doing well
we're headed towards a hundred thousand
cases per day we had 71 thousand cases
per day a few days ago we're not
handling this correctly if you look at
other countries and you look at us it's
clear that things aren't going well so
what is the outcome the outcome of
pouchy telling the truth is that the
Trump administration and the White House
try to stop vouches TV appearances this
is the stop testing to stop cases
mentality we want to have a lower case
number just stop testing as much and our
cases will go down don't like what
Anthony foul he is saying just don't let
him say it it won't change whether we're
headed to a hundred thousand cases a day
but at least you won't hear it from foul
Qi it's like saying you know if we
didn't do any pregnancy tests we
wouldn't have any unintended pregnancies
because we just wouldn't have the tests
and of course the reality is Trump
failed the administration failed the
world has stopped laughing at us now
they're crying they are they are
horrified that what by what they are
seeing here
and you know it's like we look around
the world do we understand by we I mean
that does our government understand why
South Korea still doesn't have 300 total
deaths and we're having seven hundred to
a thousand today it's because they took
this seriously
it's because they developed a test and
rolled it out quickly they did contact
tracing they isolated people with
symptoms everybody wears a masks
why does Japan have under a thousand
deaths total despite having a population
of a hundred and twenty five million
people and being geographically close to
the virus's origin in China it's because
they took it seriously and everybody's
wearing masks and it's not just the
public facing dismissals of pouchy that
are concerning again
he hasn't briefed Trump in two months
and he hasn't even spoken to Trump since
early June the White House publicly has
turned on foul Chi they've put out
statements lately saying you know we're
concerned because foul Chi has gotten a
bunch of things wrong they even took the
time to put together a list of things
foul Chi has been wrong about things
from early in the pandemic like when
doctor foul she said there probably
isn't much a symptomatic spread and of
course this is a fallacy this is a novel
coronavirus everybody got things wrong
the people who said no one would die got
things wrong Trump saying we have 15
cases which will go to zero that was
wrong the difference is fout she
corrects himself as science does since
it has a built-in error correcting
mechanism Trump never apologizes Trump
never corrects himself he never admits
that he was wrong that's the danger and
none of this is surprising I mean at
this point there are almost as many
conspiracy theories floating around
about doctor foul Chi as there are about
Bill Gates and it's not a big shocker
that all of a sudden
Trump is no longer listening to doctor
foul Chi the only chakras foul she
hasn't been fired now
we could if we wanted to criticize
doctor foul Chi we could say he was too
soft on Trump early he shouldn't have
sugar-coated the job the administration
was doing early but I get the logic if
out she just straight-up calls out from
burly and sounds the alarm says Red
Alert
this guy's incompetent he's failing he
probably gets fired right away and
there's a calculus to be made does a
sort of restricted foul Chi but in a
position of power give us a better
outcome than foul Chi being fired and
replaced with some total trump sycophant
I don't know the answer I get it foul
Chi likely made the call that he thought
was the best in the net it's not easy
but one argument would be foul she has
effectively been fired anyway in the
sense that he's been sidelined he
doesn't talk to trunk Trump and he's
dissuaded from doing interviews I'm not
pretending to know the answer one last
thought I tweeted recently we all know
that eventually when it's over they'll
try to blame foul fee and not Trump in
some of the sickest revisionist history
you can imagine I tweeted that early
this weekend the reality is it's already
happening it's already happening and
when we you know they say the winners
get to write history who are the winners
here if people keep dying and dying and
dying I don't know and we can't allow
them to revise history in that way we'll
continue covering this on our Instagram
page follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me while you're there I ran into
an entitled guy yesterday in Boston and
I called him out and I filmed it and
it's on my Instagram page okay I'm half
kidding but I'm serious as well David
Pakman on Instagram